[Musica]
quando sono nato mia madre ha detto che
già tipo mi muovevo avevo un senso del
ritmo qualcosa che è comunque lasciava
pensare al fatto che è un giorno avrei
anche possibilmente fatto musica
La cosa che più mi preme in questo
momento è il fatto che qualcuno mi ha
detto che dovevo stare dentro questo
cerchio rosso
e mi viene voglia
di uscire fuori da questo cerchio No ma
lo devo fare solo per un attimo e ci
rientro
[Musica]
ho cominciato subito da piccolo a
pensare di poter fare musica
lo dicono anche i ricordi dei miei
fratelli più grandi di me che venivano a
darmi leggere cozzate quando mi vedevano
davanti allo specchio
tentare di cantare delle canzoni
inventate in un inglese maccheronico
mentre facevo dei movimenti strani con
un pezzo di legno che voleva essere una
chitarra
[Musica]
sono Calogero nalfino e sono nato il 7
maggio del 1973 ad Agrigento
il parto Fu uno di quelli
distopi distoci Insomma mi hanno tirato
col forcica
e mi hanno provocato un leggero problema
all'arto superiore destro
Ma sono stato molto fortunato
perché
questo mi ha posto nella condizione di
poter fare quello che volevo io come
volevo per due motivi
[Musica]
il primo avevo l'appoggio di mia madre
il secondo ho avuto l'appoggio della mia
famiglia tutta ma soprattutto dei miei
amici e delle persone che ho incontrato
nella vita che mai dico mai mi hanno
fatto notare che io avevo un qualcosa di
diverso rispetto agli altri soprattutto
in quell'età che qualche mamma o qualche
insegnante reputa difficile per cui i
bambini non hanno freni inibitori e
dicono tutto quello che vedono non c'è
stato mai nessuno che mi ha detto tu hai
un problema mai nessuno e poi questo è
stato una rovina
per loro non per me che ho fatto
esattamente quello che volevo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la prima
non voglio dire la parola perché mi sono
proposto anche questo di salire su
questo palco e non dire mai la parola
del tema
la prima sensazione di voler variare il
mio percorso
l'ho avvertita quando avevo 14 anni
e avevo cominciato a scrivere le mie
pierine canzoni a mia madre dovete
capire una cosa che disse subito a mio
padre Nene il bambino deve andare a
scuola di musica
e mi comprarono invece del pianoforte
che costava troppo caro e mio padre mica
poteva pensare che facevo un
investimento del genere No prima vediamo
come va compriamogli un organo rodeo 61
della Gemma tutti già un tasto e c'era
sto coso che faceva
tecnica
per andare a scuola
fino a quando mio padre ha detto
pigliamogli un pianoforte
non si può dire e non lo dico
[Musica]
ho cominciato a scrivere le mie prime
canzoni
erano delle cose diciamo
da ragazzini
ci fu una ragazza che si chiamava Masha
nobile
aveva 12-13 anni e lei decise di
lanciarsi nel vuoto perché probabilmente
aveva avuto delle incomprensioni
probabilmente non aveva retto a qualche
tipo di emozione
E questa ragazzina mi spinse a scrivere
la mia prima canzone e mi domandai per
intere giornate perché questa ragazzina
l'avesse potuto fare un gesto del genere
e poi nel tempo
ho capito che
quando io ero piccolo
il nuovo quello che arrivava poteva
anche sembrare terribile ma non ci
sentivamo portati a
chiuderci davanti a questo perlopiù ma
c'era qualcuno che non reggeva al nuovo
non reggeva a quello che accadeva non
reggeva certe emozioni e forse Masha è
stata una di queste persone
[Musica]
è stato un brutto e un bel ricordo
perché mi ricordo che a 13 anni salì su
un palco cantai questa canzone
e poi
cominciai ad avvicinarmi a Rocco
allevimetal Ecco quest'altra variazione
sul mio percorso
partivo dal pop partivo da dj Television
partivo dai cantanti inglesi che avevano
quei ciuffi due orecchini io già 8 anni
avrei voluto due orecchini ma mio padre
è Non me lo permetteva mica cioè sia
Chiara sta cosa io i buchi alle orecchie
ne ho fatta 15 anni e mettevo un filo di
lenza dentro quando tornavo a casa per
non fargliene accorgere tornavo la sera
tardi perché se se ne fosse accorto mio
padre mi avrebbe vietato allegnata e me
l'avrebbe chiusa su un di schiaffi le
orecchie ai buchi però ce l'ho fatta voi
e insieme a questo facevo un'altra
sofferenza studia se studi ti compro un
altro pianoforte se studi ti compro un
sintetizzatore papà ma io voglio la moto
Però io ho visto zittatore Bellissimo E
alla fine riusciva sempre a fottermi io
a piedi con sintetizzatore e i miei
amici che scorrazzavano su una ruota
davanti a me e hai appresso anche questo
per me era musica e l'ho fatto per la
musica l'ho fatto perché tutto quello
che mi circondava ma la cosa più
importante era la musica
[Musica]
sono stato un pessimo studente
ho affrontato
la musica come la religione
ho pregato e studiato quando c'era
bisogno
Quindi direi che è proprio sono il
classico
studente diciamo è cattolico del momento
e ho più studiato che pregato perché
come vi ho detto poco fa sono stato
fortunato Sono vissuto in una famiglia
che non mi ha mai fatto mancare nulla E
questo mi ha portato a pregare poco
ogni tanto mia madre mi portava da un
insegnante di musica il quale
[Musica]
solennemente è molto onestamente e lo
ringrazio ancora oggi disse signora suo
figlio lo deve portare a casa e non
riportare mai più qua perché tutto può
fare nella vita tranne studiare musica e
aveva assolutamente ragione perché io
non avevo voglia di studiare musica Io
avevo voglia di fare musica che è
diverso è la musica è una di quelle arti
che si presta a questo se tu ce l'hai
dentro lei ti piglia per mano e ti porta
dove vuole L'importante è avere queste
orecchie così grandi e poter Ascoltare
tutto quello che ti capita Ecco un'altra
variazione del percorso
[Musica]
e il jazz
fai quello che ti pare
fallo e se la gente non lo capisce
allora è Jazz lo dicevano in un film
molto bello che c'era un pianista
sull'oceano mi pare che è Baricco no
Baricco ha scritto questo libro No La
leggenda del pianista sull'oceano 900 No
sì e Baricco ha scritto un libro
che si intitola i barbari
saggio sulle mutazioni Ah l'ho detto
mutazioni Ecco perché adesso sono più
grande sono cresciuto è un problema Il
mio problema è che voglio continuare a
fare musica
[Musica]
Allora a un certo punto della mia vita
incontro un gruppo di ragazzi o 23 anni
o una moglie matta di raccontare tutto
quello che mi accade intorno di
raccontare che la mafia è una montagna
di merda
di raccontare che vorrei che la
legalizzassero le droghe leggere di
raccontare che che tutto si può fare in
musica con un ritmo che fa un
[Musica]
quello bontà questo non si dice questo
non si fa Io lo dico lo faccio io lo
dico lo faccio perché posso perché
Perché dietro c'ho un papà che permette
di studiare Ecco alcune rivoluzioni
nascono così perché è il tempo di
sparare tutte le minchiate che vuoi
perché non devi andare a servire pizze
in pizzeria non devi andare a lavorare
in qualche altro posto lo sai quei
lavori quelli che si fanno con la scheda
rotta che torni lì la sera a casa No
e non sai voi che faccio dormo o mi
metto a scrivere canzoni
rivoluzioni Eh beh tutto più facile
quando tuo padre ti dice
Oh devi studiare
se studi ti compri un sintetizzatore
se studi puoi andare avanti perché
qua il futuro si fa mattone su mattone
mattone
su un mattone e l'arte La musica è
diciamo una via secondaria un qualche
cosa di cui comunque puoi fare a meno
[Musica]
tant'è che noi adesso ci sentiamo come
produttori di macchine da scrivere in un
mondo nel quale tutti Compreso chi vi
sta parlando stiamo tutto il giorno così
[Musica]
camminiamo così
respiriamo così
non alziamo mai la testa giriamo intorno
a questo cerchio rosso così
[Musica]
non c'è nessuno però che
mette il piede fuori lo sai perché
perché non è corretto non è educata
Allora proviamo a rientrare di nuovo
dentro al cerchio
mutazioni
mutazioni allora
si racconta che quando Beethoven
[Musica]
presentò la nona un giornale di se è una
canzone per gente che non ha un futuro
per gente pacata se voi leggeste questa
critica che fece questo giornale nel
1824 Se non ricordo male forse il 7
maggio del 1824
allora
capireste che è la stessa identica cosa
che accade a noi musicisti Oggi quando
sentiamo qualcosa di nuovo e abbiamo
paura E allora questa paura ci porta a
giudicare in qualche modo male il futuro
quello che vi arriva e invece no A un
certo punto mentre fuori non ci facevano
uscire perché dovevamo stare dentro un
cerchio rosso perché era giusto così
allora io sono rimasto a casa mia
e ho detto a quei ragazzi con cui
avevamo principito un percorso di musica
di un certo tipo ho detto ragazzi
io ho bisogno di
respirare aria nuova e voglio dire delle
cose che con voi in questo momento non
posso dire Allora mentre fuori si
pandemiava
dentro casa mia si cominciava questo
progetto che mi porta ad andare in giro
e raccontare una nuova forma di Lello un
po' più elettronica magari un po' più
ammiccante magari aperta al nuovo aperta
a quello che c'è in giro lo sapete
perché Perché io il nuovo lo considero
lo sprono quel momento per portarmi a
fare una nuova rivoluzione ma non da
soli perché le rivoluzioni non si fanno
da soli un po' come quelle donne che per
ora dall'altra parte
ad Oriente in Siria Iran stanno
insegnando a noi uomini che non ci
vogliono gli attributi per fare le
rivoluzioni ma ci vogliono solo due cose
cuore
e coraggio
Grazie mille
[Musica]
Lino costa
[Applauso]